white rapper he realized all right
Joseph there's a movie it's very bold
it's very risky what were you hoping to
convey with this I want to do a
simulation of what life is like in 2018
it is a experience of walking on
eggshells hmm where you have to be very
careful what you say Joseph Kahn is
perhaps best known for directing some of
the biggest music videos in the world
[Music]
including several of Taylor Swift's Andy
tells et his new movie bodied was
actually inspired by one video in
particular
[Music]
I heard that body is based off of the
wildest dreams music video can you
explain that what ended up happening was
that we had a little bit of controversy
you know whenever I do any video for
Taylor the media industrial complex
loves to create any sort of controversy
because it's good for business something
to talk about something to spread out
something to put a little hit peace out
there and and we all get to like chatter
and you know get her hits and stuff like
that yeah
so that week you know okay that week it
was the it was a little controversy
about about the nature of how I made
that particular video in the location
that I had right so I you know she of
course is silent about this she never
speaks about any of the stuff me I'm a
little bit more rebellious so I I fought
back a little bit I justified it because
I felt like there was some accusation
that were not correct you know and no
matter what I said
everyone would start calling me names
that sort of feeling of being attacked
for something you said with the
progenesis of bodied does she know that
yeah a little bit I think I told her
about the movie that I was making and
that happen do you have to have that
conversation with her no I think she
handles it beautifully she is so much
more mature than me
what is the hardest shot that you've
ever had to set up or that you've
accomplished on a music video the
hardest shot that I've ever done no one
has ever asked me that in 30 years we
did a wildest dreams video for Taylor
Swift where I was shooting in New
Zealand and I had two helicopters fly me
and Taylor around to the top of a
mountain where she had walked barefoot
on the mountain on the mountain yeah so
that's probably my hardest shot I
guarantee you we we've had human beings
walk on mountains that no one had ever
walked on before where her feet I mean
did they hurt yeah yeah yeah has she
ever it was at an injury like has she
ever been injured none of my set no I'm
thankfully no I'm safety first but she
cares about the art so much that she was
willing to sacrifice her oh yeah she
she's her body she's when she does a
video she's a hundred percent committed
it's it's really phenomenal to watch I
think that's why she's so successful
because she's willing to completely one
take the music video seriously and put
all the effort she can into it when it's
surprising when when you work with her
um she's not like a big superstar like
sort of making you wait on her nails
she's just sitting on a chair like
patiently waiting for you to set up the
shot like really just a chair waiting so
it's incredible to see I wish that
reputation was a visual album was that
ever a conversation uh no no no are
there more music videos coming i I don't
know you really don't know I don't know
are you ready for
when we see those hidden messages in her
music videos whose idea is that
is that a collaboration it's usually
collaboration but when it really comes
down to some of the deeper messages
those are all Taylor and then when we
saw all the in look what you made me do
video all the different Taylor's was
there ever a conversation to have that
play out more through the reputation
videos or was that just for that one
video that was just for that one
particular video and and I think it was
like the entire thing came from a
discussion because we're trying to
figure out how to end the video because
we had this very big elaborate video as
you saw yeah but we just couldn't figure
out an ending and then we suddenly
decided you know what it would be cool
of all the Taylor's talk to each other
and that was it really
oh there she goes playing the victim oh
yeah if there was a song on reputation
that you could do a music video for that
has not been released as a single what
would it be I think I've made the videos
that I've wanted to make give me one I
think I think I never ever talked about
the songs that I haven't done I only
talked about songs I have done
you